I'd rather be like on the best dressed
and the worst dress I don't want to be
that's fine that's the kiss of death
risk taking is the fun of it all I have
a relationship with my clients that they
feel safe enough to take those risks
I've been working with Tracy Ellis Ross
for five years Tracy and I were at the
Couture show in Paris there was these
voluminous dresses Tracy was like I've
got to wear something to the Emmys this
dress was so extreme at the time it's
huge we're like is this dress crazy and
what I love about Tracy too and very
similar way is to Justin she's quite
Fearless she was like nope it's amazing
as she stepped out of the car her
publicist was like oh you're wearing
that that's how we knew we got it
that moment shift it volume and
silhouette on the carpet
[Music]